[Music]
could you tell us a little bit more
about the
open source scientific computing tools
that are in use at ibm
and specifically which tools are
actively in use within your group in ibm
sure now ibm is a big company
and open source is has been a major part
of ibm going back
uh 20 30 years remember we were the ones
behind pushing
linux into the enterprise way back then
and since then we've continued to
have a lot of open source we have i
think at this point over 60 000
ibm developers who actively work with
open source
in their daily lives so on the
scientific computing side if there's an
open source package that has
any degree of use in the enterprise
chances are there's an ibm product that
uses it
as a dependency or in fact pushes it to
the front as a major feature
now my own little corner of ibm is
codeine the center for open source data
and ai technologies
and we work on a particular stack that
is central to
ai and data in the hybrid cloud
so apache spark for data processing
tensorflow
pi torch and onyx for deep learning
jupyter notebooks
and appendis data frames and things like
scikit-learn
for data analysis and exploratory
analysis
as well as kubeflow to cover getting all
these tools
onto kubernetes and making them work in
the cloud in a modern cloud
what makes ibm so motivated to help
sponsor the open source
scientific computing ecosystem and
specifically the pi data conference
series
there are several different reasons so
in a big partly because a lot of the
um users of ibm products
are working with the pi data stack
anyone who is using
cloud pack for data anyone who is using
studio anyone who's using our spectrum
computing high performance computing
stack
they are going to be using pi data
technology and stuff
stuff managed by num focus under the
covers
and it's very important for us as a
company to maintain a good connection to
our users
[Music]
you